okay for people who are joining this
livestream we are talking about language
completeness and consistency fourth
language when we have a variety of
things on our agenda today all right
first one storage location I don't know
what that is but we're about to find out
right so this is the issue of we have
various things like you know audio
capture and speech synthesized that want
to create files sort of semi anonymous
files on disk yes and you know where
should they go and sort of I mean that
this other notebook is sort of our
longer discussion notebook from the
dedicated meeting in case we need it but
I've sort of summarized my
recommendation and my reasoning in in
the agenda there so which is right and
basically the two final candidates are
basically either putting things in the
user documents directory as some
functions have already been doing or to
use local objects and I think using user
documents directory is the better route
and if you open up the little sections
there you'll sort of see the reasoning
but the basic reason is that files in
user document directories are sort of
you can find them there their actual
files so if you want to use them for
anything outside of the language they're
very easy to use
whereas local objects you know they sort
of look like files but they're not
really files they're directories with
different files in them and during the
hidden portion of the file system so
they're sort of much less easy to use I
personally am NOT a big fan of people
being able to take all this stuff that
we're not thinking very carefully about
that's really just cache files and
exposing them I mean I'd much prefer to
see them in local objects with perhaps
utility functions that allow you to
manage those local objects and things
like that you know
trolled way rather than making people
think they know what they are and then
getting confused and they delete one and
then things go bonkers and they say oh
you you know it's all messed up or I
don't understand that statement I mean
the if if you audio right these aren't
really cache files I mean if you do
audio capture you you are recording
something okay and then you record it
somewhere okay but so in the cloud
mm-hmm same thing and these will be
anonymous cloud objects correct I don't
know how you could do audio capture in
the cloud
well you can you can do audio capture in
the cloud
do we need people from the cloud team
here because I think that it will just
work to go I think it will turn into a
cloud object I mean I can try doing it
right now
sure let's see oh for goodness sake it
has lost my login again this is really
broken it should not be asking me to
sign then again okay let's try it
Oh not working I thought this was
working well okay so I can't test it but
whatever does in the cloud I think it's
saving into cloud objects well arguably
even in the cloud it should be saving
into some kind of subdirectory in the
cloud of cloud objects so somehow they
should be indicated because if it's like
well I don't know I mean there's some
kind of you you Aidid objects basically
okay who else here is involved in this
question cuz I mean do we actually have
the right set of people here yes we have
you have we have shadi we have Roman I
think those were sort of you know we
have John and Ian
okay I'm Nick oh so is Nick here yeah
yes he's here
yeah okay so your cache files right the
the entity store cache files those are
in the local object store is that
correct they're not in the local object
store at the moment or where are they
they're install our user base directory
right yeah they mean they the cache file
system predates local object store and
we didn't migrate over because the we
wanted to have initial compatibility and
there was and I think you are confusing
two different issues I mean these are
not cache files right these are things
we don't want to automatically disappear
you know I understand I understand there
are two categories here ones that are
actually storing real data and ones
which are okay so that's the location of
the of the local object store that right
library slash whatever slash object
slash UUID
right okay so I mean there are two
categories of things I think there are
cache files and there are somehow
permanent files those are two types of
things files that contain real data that
you now is there anything over any gray
areas there did you understand what I'm
asking I mean so in other words there's
their files which if you were to blow
them away they will always be
recoverable from the cloud now I would
say that the persistent object system is
another way to recover if you understand
what I'm saying right so one way to
recover is they're just public this
public entity store data that is being
cached locally by a particular user but
it's always recoverable from the global
knowledge base right another case is
it's a local cache of something which
you are storing in the cloud for example
and which can be refreshed from the
cloud does that make sense Roman can you
can you speak to that please
Roman II
here yes yes I'm here can you hear me
yep okay I mean one thing that I think
we need to keep the parties when you
work entirely in a crowd I mean you
still have two different sets of areas
you have your home directory and your
cloud objects and they just happen to be
on the same the same machine when you
work on the cloud but what we're trying
to get rid of stuff that's home
directory related I mean okay in
principle confusingly enough one could
have a local object store in the cloud
couldn't one yeah I mean that's
perfectly supported and it's just as
local as is the local object on your
desktop so if you want to exchange files
then you should always use the cloud
location because that is been accessible
from anywhere from the cloud itself and
from your desk oh all right but so I
have to say I believe that we should be
using for these persistent files we
should be using the local object store
for the cache files it's less clear to
me what we should be using okay so it's
all you you obviously don't agree with
this so what is your point of view so
right so the you know the file right my
audio captures or whatever if I want you
know to email them or import them into
you know my my iMovie project or
whatever if they're in user documents
directory I can just you know open the
file and stick it in there it's there
okay good some other examples so audio
is one example shadi can you speak about
other examples I mean in other words are
they going to be file extensions like
mp3 or JPEG or whatever that anybody
else understands or are they our you
know you know private file extensions we
have on the list of functions we also
have out of court image operations like
image file apply image file filter I
understand those will have JPEGs and
things once exactly right so what we're
talking about we're talking about JPEGs
are talking about WAV files or mp3s
we're talking about
in the future oh yeah what about
datasets what's dataset gonna do because
it's gotten out of out of core mechanism
as well and what our notebooks gonna do
when they have out of core mechanisms
they understand my question I mean so I
get your point and it's not a bad point
that if they are standard file
extensions then you can potentially pick
them up and do things with them although
their names are uu IDs aren't they yeah
typically on this unless explicitly
specify how would you specify them like
audio capture can take a file path and
then you can say explicitly you can
target location option right so so I
mean there are sort of two things you
might want to do right you might want to
name a you know give a special name and
you you know but keep it in sort of the
default directory or you might want to
you know specify a sort of target
directory and and you know have
anonymous objects in there and I mean
the this option doesn't exist yet and in
fact it's not even designed which is why
I said possible future options and the
agenda but you know that's sort of you
know where that you know separating you
know the the okay I get it I understood
let me ask another question is it
basically intended that this this is
only going to work well when kernel in
front end are running on the same file
system I'm trying to figure out you know
that's good I'm trying to figure out how
things work if they're if they're on
different file systems and it seems
challenged seems wrong to me though well
I think I mean I think the these are
always refining everything in this
notebook is referring to the Colonel's
file system no it isn't sure isn't
audio capture is happening in the front
end no it's maybe it's streaming stuff
to the colonel file system the audio
capture doesn't happen in the front end
and there's a little yeah audio capture
yeah what Steven means which is not
quite the same thing is that you know
audio capture is you know it's through a
user interface that's happening on your
system but does that user you know can
you even instantiate such a user
interface with the remote colonel
unless Oddie's team is doing some really
interesting stuff I'll bet the answer is
no well what is the answer shadi we have
we have we also have a no GUI version of
audio capture we just get the samples
from audio device and save it in the
file
yeah but can you get it from a device on
another system like the system the front
end is running on right so now you need
to check that oh okay so that's it
that's a I mean that relates to this
client value mechanism that we really
need to get which is this way of being
able to request something from a remote
client that has a sensor of some kind on
it okay let's loop back again so one
thing I need to see is a list of all of
the different things that we are trying
to store okay which I don't see here so
so I mean the things that I'm aware of
our audio objects in that other target
location well I think well I mean
there's a list of sort of the main
things in the agenda but look at
existing behavior well no because I
think I don't know I think that's
confusing way too many different things
missing right the working directory
URL download saves files and temporary
directory does it clean them up
well the OS will do that for you
that's if it's in the temporary
directory yes cash-based directory so is
that the same place that is dollar cash
based directory the same place that um
um next stuff saves - I know third okay
though although arguably should give him
that we have something called cache
based directory I wasn't even aware this
existed I guess or is this a cache of
local objects and now the cache of files
no no no it's a cache of anything it's a
cache of what you get when you for
example local cache of a URL but look
what it's creating it's creating local
artists it's not creating five local
local cache is that particular function
that's triggered a creation of a
spacetime activist the idea has always
been that other caching mechanisms could
use it to so we have all the caches in
one place which makes it easy to wipe
them if you spend all our money get okay
so so where is the local object-based
directory
total local base now this depends on the
operating system now apparently on the
Mac there is a dedicated caches
directory and another other ones I mean
it's a fairly standard place where they
these things are supposed to be right
and the things that go on cache in the
cache directory are precisely those
things which if they blow if they're
blown away nothing is lost because
they're really just caches I mean as far
as the operating system
concerned that's sort of a bright-line
rule
sorry I just paste out for a second
could you say that again please
so the so until they library caches you
know but by definition is supposed to
store exactly files yeah if you blow
them away nothing is lost cuz they're um
look at this this is crazy
we got to decide is it library Wolfram
or is it you know I mean this isn't this
is no no that's that that is that is the
OS standard location okay and on you
know on Linux it would be dot Wolfram no
it would be thought I forget what it is
on Linux and Windows has some other
crazy you know app data caches whatever
I had a question about dollar user
documents directory especially given the
idea that we should stick things there
so that they're accessible shouldn't be
a cloud objects in the cloud instead of
just a path Oh possibly what is it in
the cloud is it you know I I see it as
slash Wolfram cloud slash user file
slash unique stuff to the user not a
cloud object right but they can't you
can't you do things in the cloud with
that file path not properly because if
you do stuff if you act if you access
and particularly create maybe that's not
or talk well we are kind of talking
about that if you create files in the
cloud just using the pass and not as a
cloud object then it's not visible in
the GUI filesystem and that sort of
thing that's that's an interesting
question that you know perhaps we should
bring up to cloud folk is being
discussed but I think there are plans to
make that file system visible and
manageable so the cloud interface okay
so listen listen what's happened with
the cloud
[Music]
um let me show you something I mean so
so right now
we have this craziness where we have the
published directory as one of the
directories in the home directory that
is changing the home directory is going
to be at the same level and published
and the other special directories are
going to be at a higher level and so we
certainly have the opportunity there to
put some things you get what I'm saying
um
right so look first of all I think this
is gonna need another meeting because I
think we need a better list of what all
the objects are who is project managing
this particular thing it's me
okay so you need to go find out what um
um the UM um you need to go go inventory
what all of these different things are
so the ones that I'm I didn't even
remember about URL download okay um gosh
there's a lot of stuff here
which i think is mixing several
different classes of objects yeah I
understand that the ones that we want to
be temporary okay so let's understand
what what categories of things we want
okay we want things that go to the temp
directory things going to temp basically
okay
things that are cached they could be
blowing away but you don't want them to
be blown away on reboot yep I like
Nick's stuff okay then we want I'm gonna
take another category things that are
really are internal to the system but
permanent okay
so of those I'm imagining you know that
that plenty of the there's a bunch of
local object stuff that is in that
category right now you know obviously
most of the things that are in dollar
dollar user base directory are in that
category like your kernel in it are them
and your front-end in it dot M no but
those are not okay internal to the
system internal for system so that means
the user is not expected to understand
them understand them I see um things
that are user understandable user
modifiable potentially but permanent
right things that are externally user
modifiable so here not externally user
modifiable right right and there's I
mean I don't know that this is a
distinct category from from these a
disjoint category from these four
categories but you have also cases where
you are manipulating
things rather than one at a time but in
groups right and so that has a Wirthlin
example like image image file apply
filter apply I forget sorry can you say
please image file apply and cryo filter
but I I think that goes into that
category that are externally user
modifiable right although just sort of
the defaults and the controls you want
might be slightly different right
because you might want to say you know
each new file should have this appended
to the name right you take the source
file and you add this to the name and
then you would put in the extension
right it's it's you know it's not right
it's it's it's it's not necessarily a
difference in how we look in you know
where we locate some problems listen
listen Devon purposes I
please note where I'm putting this sure
okay persistence and initialization file
locations and we also having a condition
as I mentioned that is the visibility
like is it local or is it your out right
so that this is case one so this is what
is it what what is it
and then there's where is it
and that's basically local and then well
as local there's cloud there's local /
local local Fe / kernel right local /
okay so
a different thing that's a different
issue okay so remote colonel right okay
so another if the question is where will
it be used right um what is it
associated with okay so one possibility
is colonel
another possibility is a notebook now
that's a tricky case because for example
for the you know that that relates to
John's stuff about remote assets for
notebooks right and in fact when it's
associated with a notebook I strongly
think it should be in a local object or
a cloud object well so I would strongly
disagree with that because if I want to
send a notebook and it's in my local
object right look it won't work right so
why don't we want it next to the
notebook so I know to send be done no no
we're not gonna do that that's a mistake
that I mean it in no I mean if we're
gonna do this we should do it with some
persistence location where you know when
you say you're gonna send the notebook
it tells you just like we're doing with
with the audio objects you know do you
want to store it locally okay okay
persistence location that stores its
data right inside the notebook so it's
always there okay all right
John John you were gonna say yeah so if
we had compound notebooks
does anyone going to argue that it
shouldn't be inside the notebook file
proper well I would say the compound
notebooks of directories aren't they
well you know we haven't really speck
them out yet and there are some
interesting questions which merit
raising but but yes the notion is that
the notebook essentially has a mini file
system attached to it right well I'm not
sure about that I mean there's the
horror of you know moving around HTML
you know bundles that doesn't work very
well right just like a tip file a tip
file is a finger fire but I know what
you don't want a single file because
you've got a you know 100 megabyte you
know some weird hundred megabyte data
set you do not every time you do
something with you you know open the
notebook for example you don't want to
be schlepping a hundred megabytes of
gunk err
right so it really should be a separate
file it is well I mean I mean if you
know I it seems to me the question is
how much do you want the information in
the notebook I mean if you want it in
the notebook surely you do want to
schlep all right but that's exactly what
we're dealing with here okay that's
exactly the the the freedom that we have
here this is asking you do you want to
store it in the notebook or not right so
when you send the notebook you might
want to send that along or you might not
is that I'm not sure I've ever seen
whatever prompt it is right I mean
Steven on a modern computer if you
double-click on a gigabyte zip file and
then double click on my name of its
members it opens instantly there's
absolutely no overhead with the so what
I mean so I don't understand what you're
saying that well that it can be a single
file but to all intents and purposes it
behaves like a kadai rectory that just
automatically opens are needed but
because it's a single file it's much
easier to keep coherent okay well that's
the future proposal for notebooks and I
mean I don't know that we actually want
to for compound notebooks to be
directories but you know Apple doesn't
seem to have had problem making keynote
files or iMovie files or anything
directories I control the operating
system as well which kind of helps right
but John what what is the time scale for
compound notebooks well I mean that's a
good question you know it depends on the
priorities of things the I mean you know
what we could do you know on a much
shorter time frame is we could spec on
in some detail what it would actually be
and come to an agreement on that and
once we come to an agreement on that we
can probably you know say better how
long it would take to implement it all
right fine but but if that's the case
then what that is implying
is that in the future these storage
locations for example for audio capture
would actually be in the notebook bundle
well is so you know I mean there's some
there's some tricky things around this I
would say that would be a possible
location I mean right I think it's the
best location because then they would
get can move depends on what you want to
do with it right if I'm using audio
capture to you I mean maybe you're going
to fire me for this but if I'm create
using audio capture to create a birthday
you know movie for my mother I might do
some of my audio processing in
Mathematica but I'm not going to be
sending her a notebook right I'm going
to be sending her some mp4 or something
that you can just watch then export it
next for that yeah use X plus I don't
know digging around just because you
know how to hack file systems doesn't
mean we should ask our users to hack
file systems well but I mean you could
also argue that you're just using the
front end to end the kernel commands and
so there's no way you would want the
output to somehow end up in the notebook
it would end up in your well that's a
good question that's a good question so
this is so kernel another one is a raw
kernel right
eg wolfram engine right so that
obviously can store it in the notebook
not in any sort of useful way well and
and also it's difficult to imagine
something that that writes out things to
the notebook in real time because then
you have you know this weird situation
of a notebook that's in a half saved
half unsaved States I mean for reading
you could do that you could read
directly from the file but for writing
I've been thinking about this and I
think what you want to do is you want to
redirect things through temporary files
which then when you hit you know control
S or command us you know whatever the
state of those temporary files then get
saved back into your notebook okay look
look
we're things like the raw Colonel case
strongly suggest that there are external
files not bundled up with the notebook
and that perhaps what we should try to
do now I admit if you pick up the
notebook in your finder and move it
somewhere it's never going to work
unless well it could work on your local
file system because it refers to a local
object with the UUID right but if you
send it to somebody if you drag it into
okay let's be realistic you're not gonna
be able to drag it into your email for
example if it's really big right so the
question is so our exporting mechanisms
could ask you do you want to bundle it
do you want to create the zip file that
bundles the notebook with its assets or
not making sense well in terms of the
email problem of course that's the thing
that we've already solved what do you
mean if your focus if your notebook is
larger than I think it's ten megabytes
then we automatically you know basically
have you go through log into the cloud
have you go through the you know save it
to the cloud and send out a link e right
if you're using the send mail menu item
rather than your own mail client right
yeah so if people are going in raw then
they're going to have a hard time I mean
it's not gonna work perfectly I think we
just have to assume that when my
managing large you know large files and
large amounts of data that going in raw
might fail well but this is I mean
people are already making large
notebooks though I mean this doesn't no
no I I understand I'm talking about
notebooks that have backing data
gigabyte size backing data okay like
large audio files videos etc etc etc I
mean there are several ways these could
be saved you could say I want everything
packaged together on the chip side I
want the
data to be uploaded to the cloud and
contain an ownership link I want to
upload it to the cloud files cloud file
service and just has just sent the links
I mean there are several ways to do it
that's an interesting that last one you
just mentioned is a persistence location
that we should potentially add as soon
as we have external storage right we
could add as a persistence location
storing it in you know s3 or Dropbox or
something that make sense
Roman yes that would point Chloe have a
commute yeah um okay but but so what
we're saying then is okay let's unroll
this for a second okay you you're going
to have you have some large asset you
are going to reference it in the
notebook but it should be stored
somewhere and it could be a new local
file system it could be in the cloud it
could be in a variety places if it's in
the cloud it's probably gonna cache
locally but conceptually it's stored
somewhere now some of that conceptual
storage is not transferable to anybody
else am I making sense
sure okay so now the question is what do
we do if it was stored locally for your
convenience but it does not have a
backing in the cloud or any other public
place right what do we do so the answer
is if you send somebody the notebook
they're not gonna be able to get the
additional assets unless they are
somehow at the time when the notebook is
being packaged up to be sent right and
and I would certainly be for having some
mechanism whereby you can easily add up
you know the these extra resources but I
would like to point out that that's a
sort of a different problem than the one
where we started this conversation which
is I just want to you know record a
bunch of things or speech cases first
okay so in the toolbar that hopefully is
we're going to start seeing 412 one
soon-jong right yeah the work for the
truth the toolbar re nobody's gonna have
a toolbar yeah so among the things that
we could put in possibly is something as
an indicator that says this notebook has
non-local assets okay said more clearly
than that in other words it's the analog
of the little thing here that indicates
that it is not stored locally at this
point in the notebook see what I'm
saying
so you could if once we do that you
could always click on that and say no no
I want to store these assets locally in
the notebook or at least it gives you an
indication you know you click that thing
and it could say make me a notebook
bundle or make me give me these
different options for how I can send my
notebook to somebody else and have them
get those assets
I mean just granted there haven't not
thought that this deeply but my initial
reaction is we would just want the
button which says create a zip file with
all my resources that's not right you
don't necessarily want that you do not
want that you might want to say put this
to publish this to the cloud put this in
s3 right so that other people can
collect it even the share with these
specific people you know because because
let's say you're gonna send this to 10
people right you really don't want to be
or you might not want every one of them
to have that half gigabyte of stuff sent
to them and put in their email by the
way the zip file may not be the right
thing it may very well not be the right
thing because email may be too big for
email it may be blah blah blah blah blah
lots of different issues so I think that
is one option but I don't think by any
means it's the obvious option for people
well and and and we should but we should
be careful about focusing too much on
the email case I mean you know it's
already the case that email is
considered far too limiting for this
kind of thing by many people that's why
we have Dropbox and Google Drive and
one drive and etc okay so how will
things be transferred email is one
another is you know Dropbox like things
which you know s3 and things like that I
suppose we could consider similar and
another is you know our cloud right and
and and and I might add
github and github like things yeah okay
yeah I mean except until such time as we
have an actual compound notebook I'm not
sure how this button will go through and
find the alleged resources well we would
even define that it's easy it's things
that have that there'll be things like
this okay we know where those are in the
notebook it's like we could even imagine
an icon eyes thing where there is an
icon eyes where the icon eyes is a
non-local icon eyes well I think we have
discussed for these out of core audio
objects is to make these assets
available on the cloud and just make the
notebook small enough so that I know
we're just talking about shoddy that's
what we're just talking about okay but I
think that's a combination of your how
to transfer it's an email plus cloud I
know that's the point yeah exactly
right yeah right so I mean sorry so how
will the notebook be transferred yep
right because the underlying assets will
be transferred in other ways in fact you
can mix and match these things if you
want to would that be a resource
function then afterwards or I guess the
next section would be like in
information on the above what do you
mean well I guess like workflows I'm how
to do all this stuff yeah yeah yeah
that's that's far far downstream okay I
mean that um right so somebody's asking
on the on the live stream about a share
with button yeah of course in the cloud
we absolutely have that and we have I
mean we have shared with through our
cloud we absolutely have that mechanism
the issue is things that are the issue
is things that you're working with on
the desktop as soon as you're prepared
to use our share with button to send you
know content it's all gonna work it's
easy to for us to make that work the
issue is if you want to tie it and
you're gonna do file hacking and you
want to pick up the raw files and send
them then you could get yourself quite
tangled and the question is how much do
we want to help you to not get tangled
am I making sense is that a fair summary
I don't think that's an entirely fair
summary right because the the the the
the cloud notebook only write doesn't
reference anything on your local machine
or if it does it's broken and all its
reproach and even for you whereas here
the problem is that it's very easy to
create notebooks which are not soft and
saying no I understand that I'm saying
if you're working locally right you're
using notebooks you're just using the
raw engine whatever if you're working
locally there may be tons of ancillary
files that you're dealing with which are
local to your machine okay but then
suddenly you say well actually I want to
send my work to somebody else then and
the notebook that you have references
those local files but you're not if you
simply drag that notebook to your email
it will not pick up those local files it
will merely have a reference to a local
file that doesn't exist for the
recipient right so the problem is if you
if you use our share with button
for example then our share with button
can absolutely go through the notebook
and say oh this is referencing a local
file you probably want to send that as
well and it can say how did you know it
can give you three options for how to do
that and so on right that's all
straightforward problem is if you file
hackett and you simply take the notebook
file and drag it into your email then it
isn't going to work
people following me well I don't think
the share with button is as simple to
implement as you think or nor do i we've
already implemented it we've already
implemented it for look that's the
question how we can do I haven't and
well have implemented okay we have we
okay these things were we have remote
reference to things and files I admit we
haven't implemented it it reminds me of
save definitions I'm quite certain we
can implement it I mean we have to be
able to find all the places so for
example you know it is the case we have
to decide this is a thing on its face
referenced in the notebook right
it is not the case in the notebook if
the notebook references X but in that
kernel session X was equal to 7000 okay
now we go send that notebook to somebody
else well by golly their definition of X
will not be carried over right right
issue is things which on their face
appear to be in the notebook but somehow
don't get carried over with the notebook
right
that you write that but yes but they're
right I mean even well I mean maybe this
isn't a useful discussion but right even
that's not simple right because suppose
there's get package name right the front
end doesn't know how the kernel will
resolve that yet so that's for a for
example would be difficult problem to
solve
right there's nobody file system you're
talking about among other things right I
mean but but right but yes I just don't
think that you know I I don't consider
dragging a notebook to to a mail program
file hacking
I'm just your description point is the
Colonel state is not going to be
preserved by that right right right
right so certainly if you have get of
the variable file you know that's never
going you know well we could maybe try
to hack something up but right in
principle that's never going to work and
we think we agree agree on that I'll lay
on our live stream it's very keen to
know what the toolbar is going to look
like John do you have a mock-up of it so
we could just flash it up no that's
that's why I have parth around but he's
not in this meeting Billy I am but no
sorry okay well it's it's gonna be a
very simple thin toolbar which is gonna
have formatting stuff and a bunch of
other bunch of other things that are
useful tools to use with notebooks plus
a bunch of state information about the
notebook that we really want people to
have um it will be very lightweight okay
in any case we're not we're not going
ribbond we're not we're not ribboning
okay um the probably good model is
what's in the function repository
submission notebook okay but back to
this okay so colonel state is not going
to be transferred whatever happens
Colonel state is not getting transferred
nor is necessarily the knowledge of so
okay so the thing that we want my claim
is the case of of concern is the case
where you have something like this may
you reasonably think that it is quotes
path of the notebook or for example one
thing that's always messing me up and we
need to fix is datasets that are big and
are not stored in the notebook and in
fact they say now this isn't completely
stored in the notebook because you don't
want it completely stored in the
notebook you're you're using the
notebook as a viewer on to something
which is operating in the kernel okay
so the issue is things that on their
face appear to be in the notebook but
actually have back at backing files
how do those get to be transferred and
my claim is that so long as we can give
people a global signal that there's
stuff that involves backing files in the
notebook that you know if they dragged
the notebook into an email thing then
and they didn't notice that the toolbar
said that well tough luck they um
you know we can't really help that but
we can make it so that it's very easy
for them to you know get those assets to
be transferable either way putting them
in a global cloud or by bundling them up
in a zip file or whatever else and I
think that's the approach we should take
but I think that what we need to now
think about is for those local files
right for the files which would be
bundled up where are those files mm-hmm
I don't think at some level it matters
that much in the following sense okay
I think the notebook will be able to
find those files now there is a question
if for example for example you know I
have Dropbox right so some of my file
system is in Dropbox some isn't it would
be of relevance to me to know whether my
local cache file so here's a good
question actually let's imagine that my
local cache files are in my Dropbox
files okay and I open up again on a
remote computer the question is are
those cache files so let's say for
example I have entity store caches would
I
by virtue of Dropbox transferring now
have entity you know now have caches
entity caches on my you know second
computer or would those entity caches be
invalid for that second computer
comments from people on that now this is
why I would argue that local objects are
a good thing because what we could do in
fact this is a nice feature because
local objects are based on uu IDs what
would happen is you transfer it through
Dropbox to your secondary computer the
thing is there in your local object
store and the you know when you open up
the notebook on your secondary computer
there it is
with with something where it's in your
local object store it's got a UUID
there's a
guarantee you know the UUID guarantee
that then that would be a collision
right that you know Dropbox by default
shares something in your documents
directory and certainly if you just
dropped it right if if you had the same
username on both machines right then the
path would be the same if you saved it
in your Dropbox folder and it would work
just as well but but Dropbox can share
anything I just think no no his the
point about this is let's say you're
working in two different wolfing
desktops on two different machines okay
mm-hmm spraying out cache files right
this is the important case right they
both spray out cache files associated
with some entities you're getting from
the cloud or whatever else okay those
cache files so there are two
possibilities either those cache files
are canonically named does it the same
cache of earthquakes or something is
named the same way on both machines or
they both have you you IDs and they
wouldn't be it'll be a bit redundant but
at least they won't collide so Nick
maybe you can say what actually happens
with those kinds yeah right now there's
a canonical naming scheme so that fine
so okay which means they which means you
can obliterate your cache by by using
both machines at the same time right
well sure if if they're both writing to
the same location absolutely in there
there are there concurrency checks to
make sure that we're not reading and
writing from the same file at the same
time and if they're both using the same
cache location they can it'll allow
simultaneous reading but it will allow
reading while writing and it's what is
what are we doing with file locks for
the local file system I'm we've we've
got a lot of work going on now for locks
and the cloud file you know cloud object
locks do we have similar locks for local
files seems to me we should have those
and we should probably whoever Devon
maybe you can follow up on this the the
joel is working on the locking for the
cloud so I think it should be discussed
and not quite sure who with maybe it I
would be a good person whether we can
use similar sort of language structure
to specify locking in the local file
system that makes sense to people yeah I
mean I think you'd be good dev a central
framework the energy store has its own
mechanism because we didn't have one to
fall back on Devin you should make Joel
aware of that and then get him to meet
with it I I think it I use the right
person for this sure I mean I'd be
interested in being there as well to be
part of our next location meeting so all
of these issues which were raised
simultaneously okay so rolling back the
issue that we're talking about him okay
so what we're saying is that the main
issue is should things that are cached
be in local object store or should they
be in some kind of
hmm well I don't think I don't think
that is a question worth discussing
because the point of a cache is that
it's invisible a good cache is invisible
so we don't care where it's stored well
we need to know because if you find you
have a gigabyte sized cache and you say
I don't want to use up a hundred
gigabyte cache I don't want to use up a
hundred gigabytes you kind of got to
know where to find it
fine so so we have some mechanism of
querying that but you know all right so
let's talk about things that are not
externally user modifiable okay so there
that things like these JPEGs in your
famous mp3 and so on that would be
imprinted on external user modifiable
but they're permanent so what things do
we have that are not external user
modifiable I think pretty much
everything in the pack light system okay
and because in user base directory I
think yeah which is inside of dollar
user base directory yeah okay so so what
are you telling me right now is that we
have okay so we've got the where is user
base directory in your list of things
here so you're saying user documents
directories not use a base directory
right well because user I mean it was I
think it might have been in my original
list but it's not up to breaking weird
user base directory as the name of the
product in it of course it does it had
and it has for 30 years user base
directory is the oldest of these
variables I mean right this is well
maybe it's getting long in the tooth um
okay but it's also useful if you want to
have different settings for your
different for your different project I
don't think that's the right place I
mean the fact that packets are stored
there it's probably the reason that I've
had all this trouble with different
packets well okay
that's a different question whether
different versions of the same thing
should store in the same directory or
not
and we do have we I mean at least I mean
WolframAlpha notebook edition introduces
a product specific Pacolet so in that
sense right it has its own version of
the Wolfram Alpha Pacolet I mean I don't
think that's a very common case but we
can't could I can certainly imagine
product specific packets but that's a
separate question I mean I agree I mean
I think I think Todd just sort of stuck
it somewhere when he was creating the
Pacolet system and nobody really ever
gave it much thought because you never
documented the Pacolet system and it's
certainly something we could reconsider
but yes we have obviously dollar base
directory which it will be slash library
product name we have obviously that's
not for user files we have user
documents directory which is sort of the
default save location for notebooks when
you haven't you know I think that's
irrelevant to this list in my opinion
well it's where audio capture and things
have been using I know I think it's a
horrible mistake I think it's a
documents directory I don't think it's a
directory for backing stores these are
documents they're not they're not mp3
sure and and the mp3 is a form of a
document it's not a backing store it's
it's something I copy onto my ipod to
listen to back when I still actually
used my iPod right okay all right so
let's just again you say there's a
there's there's user documents directory
mm-hmm and what else is there
there's local a local base there's
there's dollar cash base directory um
any other things in this merry band but
the cash base director belongs into the
cached category and not the permanent
one right yeah I mean I guess that
doesn't really belong and
in this grouping but things that a
cashton can be recast so this is now the
teller temporary directory yep okay so
we do have things that are not external
you'd have to use a modifiable that we
want to store places okay they throw
that a lot cloud cloud base right which
is also some kind of permanent non user
modifiable I mean the whole cloud
objects and indeed all persistent object
time right so to the real question let's
let's boil this down again a random JPEG
that is the back is observer sample data
set
I don't think data set has user
understandable backing does anybody know
I don't think the file of data set has
in the back end is I think it's like an
MX file or something it's not user I've
never I've never seen that it's not in
memory so I don't know okay well it's
certainly coming that it has backing
stuff okay so certain things have
backing that is user modifiable and some
other things have backing that isn't
user modifiable is that a true statement
I mean that I pretty sure that's going
to be a true statement
mm-hmm okay so I think the distinction
between user modifiable not use a
modifiable it's kind of weird I mean I
think it's easier to have some function
that goes and finds which local objects
are in this category of user modifiable
and lets you do something with them it
seems to me than to distinguish oh this
happens to be a JPEG versus this is a
dot Pacolet file and can't be modified I
mean I'm I'm not sure I'm leaning
towards saying put everything in the
local based directory but I do see the
argument to have some things in some
kind of more
sort of you might modify this type of
area but on the other hand which ones at
you you ID'd I mean do we expect that
okay okay well that's a good question
which things the externally user
modifiable but permanent the question is
are they do they have UUID names did you
get what I'm asking because if they do
that's not very user modifiable it's
kind of a mess right so if they don't
have UUID names that means that it is
something like a dynamic image which
actually references a known file so what
I'm saying well I mean they currently
have UID news because you insist that
they have UUID names but you know I you
know people want to capture audio for
the sake of capturing audio they don't
necessarily think of it as you know a
language construct or they might also
want it you know just mp3 but I think
this is a different case I think if
you're using our user interface to
capture something that it's being stored
in a file for you you can say where you
want it stored and you can give it a
name and you're all happy but that's not
the default action and if after the fact
you say oh that audio that I captured I
don't want to use export to deal with it
I want to find the raw file I'm just not
that interested in that case you know if
you know beforehand I'm capturing this
for the sake of putting in your file
great give the name of the file but if
you didn't say the name of the file
you've got to UUID it anyway so under
those circumstances I don't understand
why it's not going into the local object
store I mean if you give the name of a
file then I think the user base
directory is the right place to put it
or use this document directory rather if
you give the name of a file yourself but
if you don't give the name of a file and
defaults to a UUID file I claim that
should go into the local object store
so does rename the file work to move a
local
object into an ordinary file so that I
can go oops
after the fact and not just I think that
we could make that work yeah because I
mean because you should we should I
agree we could make that work that seems
like a very reasonable for about that's
more like export because local object
has metadata attached to it so it's not
right and the other point is if you do
that rename everything's gonna get
messed up in other words the change is
pointing to it isn't it's a copy copy
file copy file export yeah I mean the
copy file from local local objects
should probably work yes right and
that's a reasonable solution to that I
think right although I would claim that
you know there's so benefit in being
able to sort of scan these things in uu
IDs sure you can you can see what they
are right you can sort them by date in
the finder file hacking by the time
you're looking at you you IDs it's
you're not looking at you your IDs
you're looking at a list of files they
you know gives you little preview so you
can find the one you want okay great you
can do that in the local object store
you know where you can't because they're
not files they're director they've been
turned into hacked up directories okay
so okay so what this is about is the
finder isn't powerful enough to show you
a kind of preview of a directory but it
is powerful enough to show you a preview
of a file is that right I suppose that's
one way of framing it what do the local
object stores metadata what does local
object metadata do for you in the
setting do they do anything for you is
it just overhead well I mean it's it's
essentially the same as in cloud objects
I mean they they store type information
but of course if it's just an empty
suite and I mean essentially just a
directory that contains one metadata
file and an MP mp3 okay is the master
data useful do we actually need the
metadata in the local object store well
to manipulate a local oak
check from within the language yes but
why just why well it's the only way that
when you access it that you actually
know what to format this was recently
named player doesn't have a file
extension well that that is not reliable
I mean you can you can export you can
create because local object names do not
have file extensions they can be
anything so it's only the last component
that would have that particular name but
it's just not reliable just same as the
cloud object I mean you really need to
me why don't we provide a utility in the
in the function repository for example
that lets you explore the local object
store I personally what I'm hearing from
this I take the argument I understand it
as arguments I think I think the
following is what we should do I think
we should default to putting things in
the local object store I think if you
actually name a file it should default
to go into the user documents directory
and I think that we should indicate on a
notebook that it contains assets that
are not locally stored in the notebook
and gives you the option to either store
them or store them in the cloud and
rejigger you know because what you might
want to do is you might want to say okay
this notebook I'm putting it into
storage now I want to publish these
things to the cloud and then have this
notebook refer to those things in the
cloud so I think I think this is where I
mean you guys should think about it some
more but that's what that's where I'm
coming out on this on the story and
Steven I just want to point out if you
scroll down just a tiny bit in the
agenda where I showed the structure of a
local object so you see the actual WAV
file is called UUID slash export and
then there's UUID slash object WL which
is the metadata why is this not called
dot wave
why does that not have a file extension
guys okay I mean that that's a question
for Charlotte
no no it's a question for Rome more
question for me I mean I because I have
the metadata I don't really care about
the name I think you should I figured it
out of file extension is that way that
way it gives the the file system of
fighting chance and I have to recheck
the code I mean I've come I'm not sure
whether that part because some of these
export formats were written by others
because the system is but I can check
contract and see how much I mean
generally I do not like the idea of
people mouthing around these directories
because it's so easy to make it makes it
make things inconsistent like if we
delete or modify the right I think we
should be at least civilized and call
that metadata wo or something like this
but whatever um I can I can look into
the file name extension TV because then
then it gives it a fighting chance I
mean it might have a magic number in the
file or something so that would allow it
to preview anyway I don't know whether
it uses magic numbers no I can I can
take internet I think most modern file
browsers are really just go by
extensions actually not I mean certainly
not in Linux it's quite the opposite I
think they go by magic numbers and stuff
like that will completely punt on text
files that don't have a text extension
yeah I've seen yes okay but I mean again
what then we're diving deep into the
jungle of different operating systems
and how they behave with great but I
think that having some higher degree of
civilization to give the operating
system of fighting chances worthwhile um
have a current from been on our live
stream which I'm trying to understand
being able to maintain live datasets and
a notebook without having to reevaluate
or dump save would be a huge asset even
if it wasn't the default
what does that mean I'm psyching you
read that again being able to maintain
quotes live datasets in a notebook
without having to re-evaluate or dump
save would be a huge asset so I see in
other words in other words having large
amounts of data that were automatically
included with the notebook which is
exactly what you are getting now if you
press the button in the audio capture
thing it says store it in locally in the
notebook then it is storing it literally
in the notebook write shadi and john
yeah yeah it makes your notebook a
hundred megabytes John oh and of course
I can eyes is the generalization of this
yes but I mean out of cor I can eyes is
potentially the future of I can eyes so
to speak or out of notebook I can eyes
so to speak um
you know what's there is actually stored
in the cloud and it's downloaded to some
local object store when you know I can
completely imagine and I can eyes a
cloud I can eyes so to speak right well
we have a method right so we which
allows you to you know compress it or
binary serialized that before you stick
it in the notebook so we could certainly
conceive of a method goes to cloud
object or something yes yes but I really
quite like that idea I think we should I
think that would be quite useful to
people so you know you cloud publish the
thing because the whole point is we have
a new assumption which is that everybody
can reach anything you've cloud
published now because mine will be true
you might be you know air gapped in some
you know strange location you might be
spending twenty two hours and an airport
waiting to take off like Mara true from
Brazil but yeah right okay um let's
let's at least try to get the store now
for data set since we have Chris Carlson
and design folk here
I thought we were we've wrapped up on we
have wrapped up yes there was one other
thing and that we wanted to propose this
kind of a target location or target
directory that instead of storing things
in the user documents directory which is
my user her shaadi documents we can
specify specify some other location if I
specify a file name for that audio
capture sure what you're specifying a
file name what you want to do is specify
the default path right well why does she
call it pause why isn't that option just
path I know that's bad idea don't we
have other cases where where we're
specifying a default directory for
things I don't think we do I mean I
can't think of one off the top of my
head why wouldn't you just specify the
directory name here why is it that you
want a option name because there's one
of these things because generally the
way we've done that is to have a
variable but I agree that it's kind of
ugly to have that in every function and
I mean it's not only director it could
be it could be a local base it could be
a cloud base it could be I mean it could
be : greater than a local base for
example sure no I mean I mean the
location may restore it need not be a
directory it could be a local assistance
location systems location take an actual
file pod but I I think I think that I
think the point is you know if we make
the default location you know local
objects but I want them to go by default
you know on my you guys to go into my
user documents directory I know I
understand that I'm saying why can't you
use as the option persistent location
doesn't persistence location already do
this I said that's not generally enough
I mean that
right I mean yeah that's a very
different context we need to think too
but I just
my main concern was the name the term
directory in the name of state option
the target location is actually not that
bad well what is the analogous thing in
the persistence world it would be it
would be persistent thing right would be
something that ends in a slash so that
it would be just like a directory but
business locations themselves are like
root directories I think this is very
similar to persistence I think it's very
much the same idea and I recommend well
first of all it's not persistence path
right because persistence past is like
past it's where to look for sorry it
might be persistence location but I
think saying it's like persistence base
which also has a form of there isn't a
persistence base without a dollar better
not that I'm not sure I would think that
was a that was an option but maybe it
isn't maybe might be an option option
here so it is an option that's a bug
right and it looks like persistence
locations ahead not an option
right so I'm saying I think this should
be somehow related to persistence base
and requires further thought um the oh
yeah related but they not just remember
the main difference is of course that
inside these persistence locations you
only store persistent objects which are
these things with metadata and
everything so it's not suitable for
specifying a local directory for a naked
fighter
okay okay fine Ethan a live stream is
pointing out that organised access to
local objects for a given notebook is
more helpful than a giant store yeah I
understand but I mean I there's sort of
a choice because it's either global or
it's not global and they're places where
you might want to share you know you
have two notebooks you're working on an
audio you know processing you know tasks
and you share them between notebooks and
you know then you can't you don't want
to copy the file so I agree with you
that being able to get what are the
local objects associated with the given
notebook that will be a useful thing to
be able to get so it will be something
like notebook local objects or something
would give you the local objects
associated with the current notebook or
it could be a current value of the
notebook or something we we really need
to wrap this meeting because I have
another meeting and then we have another
live stream for people who are paying
attention to this
um right so yeah so I think let's get
just look at the mock-ups but these were
sort of this may or may not actually be
implemented in the prototype felt but
these were sort of r2 you know I am
partial to sticking the scroll bar at
the very top so the horizontal scroll
bar at the top so that means the
vertical what's wrong with this
integrating the button into potato
sometimes the data set is very narrow I
see right like if you did so Chris if if
the data set isn't sufficiently wide
that you need to scroll it is it the
case that the scroller will be absent
yes I mean I admit that I'm not that
unpark or at the top because that's
typically where the column labels are
and you're typically looking at the
column labels when you're scrolling yeah
both at the bottom where you know who
knows what you're looking at yeah
another issue at the bottom currently is
that when you scroll the contents size
may change and it causes you to lose
tracking on the scrollbar there may be a
way to work around that but it doesn't
currently were
if it's our topic it's alright yeah I
mean if you think it's okay to do that I
mean Billy is here also right so it so
the fact that there's a gutter between
the scrollbar and the content areas is
to me it's to me not obviously correct
well there's a technical issue there so
if you integrate the scrollbar in the
frame then presumably want the scrollbar
to fill the entire frame and since the
content size will change if you really
get it I generate it you lose tracking
on the scrollbar and that may be the
reason that it was originally done this
way there is a framed version but I
think that there's some additional
technical issues with it so if you
scroll down to number three yeah there
is writing but uh yeah for the frame
around the highlighting I mean there's
no problem with putting a loose frame
around it as long as you don't expect
the scroll bars you know to fill the
frame I like this I think this is good I
think this looks a lot better that this
thing just looks like it's got little
pieces hanging out that are bugs right
like I think this with the scrollbar at
the top would be just fine and and in
the case where that okay so the only
issue is there's the the sort of the
zero case where there aren't any scroll
bars but then do you have the outer
frame how does the outer frame come in
when score bar starts sprouting to go
what I'm asking
yeah well if there were no scroll bars
at all then you would just get the naked
thing like you do now no I understand
that but you're gonna double frame it as
soon as there's a scrollbar that means
you're double framing as soon as there's
a skull bone and it seems to me you're
light for consistency you would want to
double frame it always I think that's
not gonna look sensible Billy do you
have a comment on that I mean are there
other header options that's gonna go to
the top I think you said there were
depending on your data set there can't
be a header at the top but I mean it's a
part of the grid I think the double
frame would look fine if there was you
know if it wasn't all white between the
frames
you made if it were like a panel you
know four more panel yeah sort of a
little bit more manipulate like yeah I
think we can get the scroll bars looking
a little bit more like scroll bars
instead of impacting the frame style
because we have like information and
other things which sort of follow this
lightweight kind of box approach which I
think we could just you know we could
still keep and then just put a little
bit different stylizing on the scroll
bars look I think this something like
this is gonna work this thing saying dat
Anandi notebooks store now is not very
consistent with what you're seeing here
right it's consistent with like sparse
array okay well somebody Devon I think
needs to go in and you know chase how
these you're not it isn't stored store
now stuff works because I think they're
not okay
I object basically says that the file
that this audio was linking to is
missing it doesn't say this is out of
court oh that particular one says it's
missing right but if it was there you
would have a store now button right
we won't now by we could right we need
that and my point is that has to be
consistent and look with what we have
here right if you do sparse array of
range I understand okay I really need to
go um and for people who are consumer to
let the yeah fine that's the fun thing
that's what we need that's the same
thing we need for the audio objects
right how about two fingers scrolling
that's a good question how to finger
scrolling works in the
in datasets and Chris you need to make
that work correctly you mean in when you
when you're scrolling your mouse on that
in the data set content yes yes that you
not have to go
you know Mouse ibly you know that you
can do trackpad scrolling inside them
right
that's a detailed UI thing okay listen I
go run yeah we actually made we made
some progress eventually so those who
are interested in the live stream about
predicate logic will be there in about
ten minutes okay see you soon